bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono pa vj egizia e oggi
siamo in un nuovo prima di cominciare
ragazzi come al solito devi partire con
a formare della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da daniela che
ha fatto stop disegno della madonna
bellissimo perché perché ciò le
guanciotte rosse tipo qualcosa di tappi
tra l'altro vi spunta anche un tentacolo
dal culo ma ma quelli sono dettagli
comunque ragazzi posso andare news le
maniche tipo allora in questi giorni è
capitato che ogni tanto non ho fatto un
video è successo la gente pensava che
fossi morto però non so facendo i
preparativi per registrare il film
ragazzi quindi è un casino assurdo
nonostante questo comunque cerco di fare
video sempre però magari una volta può
anche succedere che che non riesca non
muoio
forse se muoio risparmio però tranquilli
ok gesticolando come un deficiente e
comunque regala cosa carina di tutto
questo è che prendeva intensi dove devo
correre anche nel tipo che ci sono le
scene di corsa e robe del genere mi
hanno detto se non si è allenato lordi
sul tapis roulant così ti alleni insomma
fai un po di esercizio fisico e l'ho
fatto in questi giorni sono che tipo il
risultato è stato questo
[Musica]
vi terrò aggiornati su questa cosa
incredibile queste imprese atletiche che
faccio vi tengo aggiornati e detto
questo ragazzi colle chiuso finito non
c'erano tante però colpa sua siamo lo
scagioni pacchi che stavolta sono i più
strani del solito e ce ne vuole
[ __ ] per gli è crollato tutto
comunque ragazzi questo che è qualcosa
di giganti questi due un po più piccoli
tra virgolette ma parto col più piccolo
e antico cazzo adesso è cambiato non è
più della scatola delle adidas adesso
quella riciclata della nike grazie
comunque a proviamo e la prima storia
mentre che cazzo c'è dentro anche se ho
paura così si è aperto gli scappò
trovato forse questo rob era una farlo
ok grazie perfetto dovrei mette sei
sicuro di questo
[Musica]
va bè ragazzi adesso che ho questa
chioma bellissima proviamo a una
macchina fotografica ma cos'è ma
funziona oddio ragazzi guarda che roba
fighissimo tipo si vede anche dalla
webcam è una di quelle fotocamere che
cambierà le immagini tipo così è una
[ __ ] grazie di questa cosa io che volevo
farmi cis elfi sono sempre più belle per
concludere ragazzi non l'avrei questo è
fantastico erano caramelle erano dove
ragazzi a parte sta roba passiamo al
prossimo pacco che è meglio prima che
impazzisca non ne potevo più gesù santo
erano meglio i capelli di prima ora
gambe e bellissimo questo c'è roba
fantastica questo ragazzi c'è una cos'è
ma ci sono delle fan art bellissime sono
troppo sexy 9 a lei sono un film può
essere l'ultima cosa ragazzi che questo
fa riguarda l'indiretta
come ultimo ragazzi abbiamo questa
bestia che non è da lì che cosa sia ma
mi fa paura o mio dio
la sede dei vini dei vivi grazie non
bevo il vino ma ti ringrazio di cuore
amico dei belli giornali che ben 2
miliardi di giornale poi c'è un pacco
nascosto fantastico non poteva inviarmi
tifo queste invece che inviarmi 3
milioni il giornale e dentro il parco
c'è una croce a parte altri miliardi i
giornali ha trovato una una palla c'è
scritto apri tra la si apre anche questo
io conclude
[Musica]
grazie e c'era bisogno di tutta questa
merda quindi ragazzi concludo qualcuno
scarpaccio dei pacchi grazie di cuore
per tutto e passa da fare risponde prima
di commettere un omicidio
con questa mia arma letale prima domanda
io da following james fa vi risponde c'è
un sito come al solito io ormai ho il
terrore viste cose che è una roba tipo
oh mio dio che è cosa troppo figo nola
beh mica ma cosa sono un [ __ ] artista
per sé quali vendiamo e 22 milioni di
euro si bay che fa vj una fermi un
attimo che avrò mai una roba che tipo
faccio quello che voglio to premi eti
crea le cose da nove bella [ __ ] tonova
io sono ragazzi sono non dovevo fare
l'artista perché sono bravissimo questo
lo chiamò alla patata ragazzi vedono
gesù perché continua a cascarci ogni
volta che fa vj a una notizia fantastica
perché io sono fantastico quindi quando
le notizie sono tutte fantastiche la
smetto poi risponde poi però si è
velocemente quindi subito il suo video e
descrivono anche al sito ok ci siamo
ragazzi sono pronto
[Musica]
l'omaggio 36 meglio nel 90 per cento di
tutti gli utenti nelle ultime 4 grazie
le so queste cose è stato bello ragazzi
sono troppo forti
luca rossi faty ma a volte la domenica
vorresti non fare più il diciamo di sì
perché a volte sembra un po mi rompere
cazzo però diciamo che il risultato è
questo l tutti ragazzi benvenute che
sono video sono fa dj oggi non siano
service ma che non è che si può fare
sempre è primis al d'america quindi non
basta di cazzo mi farei pd smuovi il
culo solo infilo stanotte giovanni
dottore fa visto anche farina tua in
realtà sei pazzo ti fa sembrare che io
sia un pazzo
[Musica]
ping ragazzi concludo caso le domande
spero che mi sia piaciuto questo è la fa
la domanda di oggi è che cosa cazzo non
si apre ecco faccia ci dovrei mettere
dentro
ditemi voi la risposta io lo metto e gli
ero li manda indietro fate che sia
esplosivo e quindi ragazzi servito è
piaciuto la7 ha lasciato momento mi
piace anche a pace di facebook e come
non i video trovata una descrizione sono
severi city scrive tve1 prossimo vinto
belle ragazze